thanks for joining us America this is
the Dave Ramsey show have you guys heard
that there is a student loan crisis in
America have you heard that well there
is case you hadn't heard there's a
trillion dollars owed on student loans
and that is a crisis and it's not for
everyone but it is for some of you some
of you have really gotten yourself into
a mess with these student loans and so
you know occasionally we need to just
stop and tap the brakes societally and
look at something as a culture look at
something and that's something is
education let's start with the idea of
this education is valuable so long as
what you are being valuable in terms of
money it makes you money so long as what
you're being educated in someone in the
culture cares about and so getting
absurd degrees getting a PhD in German
polka history a useless degree is
useless that's why we call it a useless
degree because it's useless there's only
one job you can get if you've got a PhD
in German polka history and that is to
teach other people to get a degree in
German polka history as a professor of
German polka history that is your only
potential job that's a fairly narrow job
market and since the number of
universities offering a degree or
classes in German polka history is
fairly small you're screwed now I'm
using that as a metaphor but you know
what I'm talking about stupid but
degrees that have no application in the
marketplace whatsoever and people
spending money that they don't have on
them now let's start with this premise
when it comes to education all education
is not smart well there you go
not all education is smart some people
are stupid about education isn't that
the paradox of the world how many of you
have met people who collect degrees like
a thermometer
and yet they can't seem to make their
way through the culture and make enough
of a living to feed their own kids and
they got more letters and licenses after
their name than anybody you've ever met
now we've met those people we know
they're out there so we know that all
education is not smart so parents here's
the deal you got a 17 year old you got a
16 year old you got an 18 year old you
got a 19 year old you got a 20 year old
why don't you be a parent because you
know what I'm saying is true you know
all education is not smart so don't send
them off to colleges to go just get a
degree in anything anything just get a
degree
cuz if you don't get a degree we're all
gonna die and you won't be able to make
the money cuz you're not a college
graduate so just get a degree in
anything this is the way the culture
sounds it sounds like a beagle chasing a
rabbit it's ridiculous I just got to get
a degree in what here's an idea be smart
about it get a degree in something that
matters and I'm not down I'm not going
to make fun of a bunch of majors that
are actual real majors but you know what
I'm talking about it has to have
application in the marketplace or your
education makes you look stupid
isn't that an irony when you walk in and
you say I got a degree in X and
immediately your face turns red you know
what I'm talking about that's you I'm
talking to don't let your kids do that
stuff get a degree and learn some get
got some knowledge in an area that
actually has application in the
marketplace where the degree results in
a better job the degree results in a
better quality of income better ability
to run your own business better
something but a degree in German polka
history is not smart now if you have the
money and you run a write a check and
you've just always wanted to have a
degree that was useless and that's your
hobby is doing that that's fine pay cash
for it I don't care and the same thing
about where you go to school where you
go to schools useless truly no one how
many times you go into a doctor's office
and you go
could I see where you went to diploma
before you take my appendix out I want
to see your diploma where you went to
school now they might have it up on the
wall where you can see it because
they're proud of it
but generally speaking they pass the
medical boards their practice they have
a you know they have a practice open
they're a practicing professional how
many times you go in to hire a lawyer
and you go where'd you go to law school
how many times you done that like when
you were getting your divorce or when
you were you know when you were buying a
house and you went into clothes on the
house yes yeah where he went to law
school the girl when she went to law
school no you didn't you don't have any
idea and let me tell you ninety-eight
percent of jobs in the US and 98 percent
of career decisions in the US have
nothing to do with where you went to
school so take your prestige school idea
and stick it in your ear it doesn't work
it's a bunch of crap y'all it just does
not work in the real world out here now
there's about two percent of jobs that
care if you went to Wharton or they care
if you went to Vanderbilt they care the
rest of us we don't care I went to a
state school with the University of
Tennessee graduate with a four-year
degree and people that graduate from
Vanderbilt work for me so let's get this
straight folk this how this works you
know you've got to be in control of this
education mindset now I am NOT against
education I'm against you going into
debt for any kind of education and I'm
against you blending money that you
believe you're getting a return on
investment on ridiculous degrees at
ridiculous universities that charge way
too much and you're not getting anything
for the money you spend if you want to
spend money at a ridiculous institution
or you want to spend money at a
ridiculous
- on a ridiculous degree as long as you
have the money that's your business go
be stupid with the money I don't care
doesn't matter to me but quit borrowing
money that is taxpayer-funded to finance
your stupidity
don't be getting a degree in this stuff
I mean it's absolutely not you guys you
have to stop and think about this you
know you really have to use some common
sense in your decision-making paradigm
and most of all you parents have got to
coach your kids you have to love your
kids enough to
coach them in what they're getting into
article in Time magazine illustrating
what I'm talking about today listen to
some of the classes you can take at
college now these aren't degrees these
are classes this is stuff that people
are actually spending money on oh by the
way borrowing money on their student
loan to go to this one class is called
politicizing Beyonce
this Rutgers Gender Studies class
introduced in 2010 aims to assess us
class racial gender and sexual politics
through the music and career of Beyonce
you've got to be kidding me
zombies in popular media this Columbia
College Chicago course uses zombie
movies and comics to explore societal
issues like how people to relate to and
trust one another in times of need
zombies this class called the joy of
garbage the Santa Clara University class
explores the science of decomposition
the Eco consequences of trash and more
field trips include landfills and sewage
treatment plants your grandmother would
be so proud the science of Harry Potter
this is a college class this Frostburg
State University science course answers
physics questions with a nod to Hogwarts
for example could genetic engineering
actually create a three-headed dog
things you need to know to be able to
exist in the real world maple syrup the
real thing is this breaking you up the
Alfred dis Alfred University seminar
explores the history and mechanics of
maple syrup production and yes it also
involves making and eating some sweet
treats life-changing this one I couldn't
believe but I've read it all the way
through the underwater basket-weaving
have you ever heard everybody taking
that class I've always heard of that
class I thought it was a mythical class
the old idiom for an easy elective is
now an actual class all
at a recreational not for credit one
offered at schools like Reed and
University of California San Diego take
a class you can audit the class
underwater basket-weaving
this is what education has been reduced
to so be careful out there people stupid
is in the land and and stupid will cause
you pain and being stupid about
education is the ultimate paradox use
your brain
moms and dads use your brain parents
your kids
the answer's no we're not spending money
on that no I'll kill you no we're not
going to do that this is the Dave Ramsey
show
you